so if you can believe it christmas day
it is about two weeks away from today
and later today a toy drive for children
and foster care kicks off
and you can help and donate this morning
hector mejia is live near decatur and
sunset with more on this
great effort going on hey hector good
morning to you
hey there good morning and it's a
wonderful effort and here's a challenge
if you don't know what to buy maybe
think about your own childhood remember
about those cool toys you would get when
you were a kid
maybe a dodge ball a water gun or maybe
even a razor scooter we also have a lot
of
other toys we have some dolls here this
is my friend mary hello good morning
what is that this baby olive
no baby alive baby alive yes every
little girl had a baby alive when i was
growing up
that's really cool so um we are
collecting toys for
foster kids tell us about the
organizations but first we have some
other toys there on the counter we have
what like about
200 toys already and hasn't even started
yet
i'll look a girl and don't be like my
friend the grinch
come on by with your toys tell us about
the efforts
you know we have a number of
organizations involved and we are
collecting toys for kids in foster care
yes we are we're working with the racio
guinn foundation where ceo guillen
was shot and killed during the route 91
left behind
four children youngest six week oldest
16 years old
and her two older boys christopher and
marcus started a foundation in their
mom's honor
and part of their efforts that they do
is toy drive
so we we partner with them and we are
also partnering
with safety nevada which is a foster
care
support organization and you were
telling me the reason why you guys are
involved
the connection between camco and the one
october shooting is
you guys have employees who were there
that night and our survivors and are
you know all getting together collecting
toys during the special time of the year
for children
yes absolutely we have um several of our
employees that were there
um one young lady uh riley was actually
injured at um at the concert for me my
daughter was there
she left right before the shooting
started and we started
58 random acts of kindness because of
that and
a lot of these toys that came here today
are from our friends at 58 random acts
of kindness who have been collecting
the last month to help support this as
well and we'll get to talk to
riley at 6 30 but first uh before we run
out of time let's go over the details we
are located by
decatur and sunset starts at 9 30 this
morning and it's sort of like a drive-up
drive-through yeah we want to make it
socially distance and safe for everybody
so we're going to take
temperatures outside they're going to
drop off their toys we've got grouchy
john's coming with hot chocolate and
cookies hot chocolate
yeah we're um we have first choice tree
that's going to have a photo booth set
up out there
and we're excited to see everybody we're
at camco homeowners association
management
4 775 west teco avenue
and come on down and see us today
anytime before four o'clock
we're all excited it's all for the kids
and look at this it's like a toy store
already we have a lot of toys here
anyway we're back in a few minutes at 6
30 for now reporting live hector mejia
alex back over to you ah so cool and
hector i know you were a foster dad too
and you've
seen firsthand what a difference that
makes so anything you can do
helps this morning thanks hector good
job all right